THAT IS COMING UP.
♪
GRIFF: FLORIDIANS ARE KEEPING AN
EYE ON TROPICAL STORM FRED AND
BRACING FOR RAIN, THIS COMES AS
THE STATE ALSO GRAPPLING WITH
RISING COVID CASES AND A DEBATE
OVER SOME PANDEMIC PROTOCOLS.
JOINING ME NOW TO DISCUSS IT,
FRANCIS SUAREZ, MAYOR OF MIAMI.
MR. MAYOR, THANK YOU FOR TAKING
TIME.
I WANT TO GET TO THE TROPICAL
DEPRESSION FRED, BUT FIRST LET’S
TALK ABOUT THE SITUATION WITH
COVID CASES.
YOU’RE SOMEWHERE JUST SHY OF A
POSITIVITY RATE OF 19% HOW ARE
THINGS GOING THERE?
WHO IS MOST IMPACTED?
>> WELL, MANY PEOPLE ARE BEING
IMPACTED.
WE’VE, UNFORTUNATELY, HAD
RECORDS OVER THE LAST FEW DAYS.
WE’VE HAD A COUPLE OF HIGHS FOR
FLORIDA.
I’M ACTUALLY IN A TO COVID
HOSPITAL RIGHT NOW VISITING A
40-YEAR-OLD WHO’S IN ICU, SO
IT’S IMPACTING PEOPLE THAT ARE
MY AGE, IT’S IMPACTING CHILDREN
BECAUSE MORE CHILDREN ARE
HOSPITALIZED THAN BEFORE,
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, THIS IS A
DIFFICULT TIME WHERE WE’RE NOW
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE’RE
DOING EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN AND
GETTING VACCINATED.
YOU KNOW, 99% OF THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE VACCINATED ARE NOT
EXPERIENCING SERIOUS
COMPLICATIONS, AND 90% OF THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE HOSPITALIZED ARE
NOT VACCINATED.
SO IT’S CLEARLY A PANDEMIC OF
THE UNVACCINATED.
GRIFF: AND, MR. MAYOR, ARE YOU
SEEING THE DEBATE OVER WHETHER
TO GET VACCINATED, THOSE THAT
ARE HESITANT, AND THE MASK
MANDATES POSSIBLY COMING BACK,
ARE YOU SEEING THAT REALLY
AFFECT YOUR ABILITY AS A LOCAL
LEADER TO TRY AND GET THINGS
UNDER CONTROL?
>> WELL, WHAT WE’VE DONE IN THE
CITY IS FOR OUR EMPLOYEES IS YOU
HAVE TO WEAR A MASK UNLESS
YOU’RE WITH VACCINATED.
OBVIOUSLY, THE PREFERENCE WOULD
BE FOR PEOPLE TO BE VACCINATED
BECAUSE WE’RE SEEING THE
STATISTICS THAT SHOW
OVERWHELMINGLY THAT IF YOU’RE
VACCINATED, YOU DON’T SUFFER
SERIOUS COMPLICATIONS, AND MOST
OF THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
HOSPITALIZED ARE NOT VACCINATED.
I THINK WE’RE STARTING TO SEE A
PEND LUMBAR SPRING WHERE --
PENDULUM SWING WHERE PEOPLE ARE
SEEING CHILDREN AND PEOPLE MY
AGE BEING HOSPITALIZED, AND I
THINK THAT’S CHANGING THEIR
MINDS, AND I’M GLAD IT IS.
GRIFF: DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
REALLY THIS LATEST SORT OF RISE
IN CASES MAY CONVINCE THOSE THAT
PERHAPS HAVE BEEN RETICENT TO
EMBRACE THE PROTOCOLS TO MAYBE
CHANGE THEIR MINUTED?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
LIKE I SAID -- THEIR MIND?
I’M VISITING A FRIEND OF MINE
WHO’S 43 YEARS OLD.
HE WAS UNVACCINATE IF BECAUSE HE
WAS TRYING TO HAVE A CHILD, AND
AS A RESULT OF HIM BEING IN ICU,
MY GROUP OF FRIENDS THAT WERE
NOT VACCINATED HAVE BECOME
VACCINATED.
THAT’S GOING THE HAPPEN OVER AND
OVER, AND HOPEFULLY HE’LL BE
FINE, AND HOPEFULLY MORE PEOPLE
WILL GET VACCINATED.
GRIFF: I COULD KEEP TALKING TO
YOU ABOUT TO COVID SPIKE, BUT
BECAUSE WE HAVE YOU AND THIS
BREAKING NEWS IN HAITI OF THIS
EARTHQUAKE, HAVING SPENT A LOT
OF TIME IN LITTLE HAITI THERE,
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING FROM YOUR
HAITIAN COMMUNITY IN MIAMI AS WE
GET NEWS OF THIS EARTHQUAKE?
>> WELL, UNFORTUNATELY, IT’S
ANOTHER DEVASTATING EVENT THAT’S
HAPPENED IN HAITI.
OBVIOUSLY; THEY’RE REELING AFTER
THE ASSASSINATION OF THEIR
PRESIDENT.
YOU KNOW, THE COUNTRY IS
DISORGANIZED FROM A POLITICAL
PERSPECTIVE, AND FOR THEM TO
HAVE SUFFERED AN EARTHQUAKE
WHICH COULD BE EVEN GREATER THAN
THE ONE IN 2010 WITH MASSIVE
AFTERSHOCKS, YOU KNOW, IT’S
UNCLEAR EXACTLY WHAT THE
DEVASTATION IS OR WILL BE, BUT
THE EARLY REPORTS ARE NOT GOOD.
AND, OBVIOUSLY, PEOPLE ARE
EXTREMELY ANXIOUS HERE.
GRIFF: AND AS FAR AS YOUR
HAITIAN COMMUNITY GOES THERE,
ARE YOU GOING TO HAVE ANY SORT
OF RESPONSE TO HELP THEM,
PERHAPS TO TRY AND REACH -- I
KNOW COMMUNICATION IN SITUATIONS
LIKE THIS BECOMES REALLY VERY
DIFFICULT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I MEAN, WE HAVE, LIKE YOU SAID,
LITTLE HAITI CULTURAL CENTER
WHICH WAS CREATED IN THE CITY OF
MIAMI, AND IT’S PROBABLY ONE OF
THE LARGEST DIASPORA OF
HAITIAN-AMERICANS ARE HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES.
SO WE WILL BE USING THAT
FACILITY TO CONNECT WITH THE
HAITIAN COMMUNITY AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE’RE DOING EVERYTHING WE
CAN AS A CITY TO SUPPORT THEM
OVER THERE.
GRIFF: AND LASTLY, MR. MAYOR,
WE’RE GLAD THAT A HURRICANE
NAMED FRED IS NOT HITTING YOU,
BUT YOU ARE GOING TO GET A LOT
OF RAIN.
WHAT ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT?
>> WE’RE USUALLY PREPARED FOR
HURRICANES AND FOR LARGE
HURRICANES, SO THIS, IN A SENSE
FOR US, BEING THE FIRST STORM OF
THE SEASON IS WELCH COME NEWS,
THAT WE’RE NOT GOING TO --
WELCOME STORM THAT WE’RE NOT
GOING TO GREAT GET THE BRUNT,
AND WE’RE GOING PREPARED FOR IT.
GRIFF: OUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS